[Music]
foreign
dobby frances thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for having me so great
to have you i've been following for such
a long time
huge fan of what you do at group 11 and
and i've been reading a lot of the
things that you've been writing and
and the different interviews you've been
doing and i think your outlook on
investments
and tech in general and entrepreneurship
is really fascinating
so i'd love to to know dive straight in
there tell me a little bit about what
motivates you and i know this is
not usually the first question that
people ask you perhaps but
i'm really curious because you seem like
a person who really is driven by impact
and i want to know what impact means for
you and mainly to get inspiration from
myself
yeah no it's a it's uh it's such a
unique and great question to
kick an interview with and i assume that
the viewers uh
know who we are and they're going to get
some context through the uh
through the uh verbage that you'll
connect the video to right
definitely all right so
you're asking about what drives me um
i'll tell you something the word impact
uh is it sounds maybe a little bit too
cheesy to describe
to describe what drives me because
you know ultimately um i just care a lot
about winning
i love winning i love that
enough i love collaborating with other
people who have a similar mindset
and they're not into becoming victims
but but rather
winners people that want to define
industries or redefine industries
define categories where they operate and
what does it mean not to be a victim
what does that mean because i think you
know you're seeing a lot of this
behavior right now in hebrew we call it
a kobanut
you know i'm not interested in in
anybody else dictating my life
circumstances
and to the extent i can of course there
are four major events we're experiencing
one right now
but to the extent i can i would like to
navigate my own ship
uh and you know uh so that's uh
that's basically it and and to the
extent that i can
i can choose uh the fleet of other ships
that accompanies me
uh i'll do this just that so your
question what drives me
winning i love winning and i love
collaborating with other people who have
a similar mindset
and uh and the outcome of that by the
way because
you don't win in a vacuum right right
what is winning
you know there is a what is the
competition exactly
well the competition is reinventing
industries
and uh and within that and within my
kind of like
narrow you know uh uh habitat which is
innovation in fintech um i just love
winning
and that's uh that's the the true answer
to your uh
simple yet really complicated question
definitely i mean okay so you are a
walking winner
with uh early investments and some of
the most incredible hyper
hyper growth startups to polity and uh
and
and trip actions and and really uh i
mean you you have this
ability to go in and see and see
different
entrepreneurs and different ventures and
from the get-go be able to
sort of theorize of where they could go
and and you've seen this also on the
shark tank
tell me a little bit about this this
this reaction that you have to
entrepreneurs coming in
how can you identify who's going to be a
category winner
who's going to lead disruption and who's
going to victimize themselves
when we have something like covet 19.
yeah by the way i'm not sure about
victimizing themselves just become a
victim of
you can become a victim of covet 19
circumstances
as a founder and it doesn't mean you're
not a winner you just became a victim
because
so happens you didn't raise money over
the past years so you're not well
capitalized to deal with this particular
crisis and nobody else is investing and
so on and so forth
so i i didn't say that you know uh
the the fact that you lost doesn't that
you lost the bet right that you lost an
effort that you were undertaking doesn't
make you a loser
i'm talking about mindset i'm not
talking about the ultimate outcome the
ultimate outcome
for me by the way as an investor as well
as as is the case for many of my
founders
can also be negative despite your best
efforts and despite having a winner
mentality
it's important to remember that because
there are many other factors
uh that that contribute to your success
some of them are the market the strength
of the product the strength of the
team how much money you have raised when
you've raised that amount of money what
what is the m
a activity in your respective industry
indeed you're interested in mna
and whether forced majorities happen or
not and of course major
can be the stock market collapse in 2000
can be 2007 2009
uh global financial crisis and of course
can be covered 19
and whatever else is going to uh uh to
happen to us over the next few decades
definitely no you know when i'm thinking
also about the victimizing themselves
i'm not saying
about the outcome but i'm also thinking
about you know really now is a test of
leadership and you can see these
different ceos and founders
of how they're exerting their leadership
given the forces or circumstances
you have those that are suffering but
are saying you know we're going to go
through this we're going to come out the
other end
it's going to be tough but we'll make it
and others are saying you know what this
really sucks and i don't know what to do
and this just really sucks yeah no none
of us really knows what to do and i
think that
the the the only answer in times of
uncertainty is do you have a fundamental
belief that tomorrow will be better
right and because and because we invest
in the future and because many of our
investments remember
you look at statistics right i mean it
takes 7.9 years on average for a company
to exit from the time you invest in seed
all the way to the end
so i cannot judge i cannot judge and
make
significant decisions related to any of
my existing investments
or my desire to make new investments
based on a moment in time i consider
this
in time and and i have to make a
decision right now
how do i view the word do i believe that
things will get better or worse i
believe things will get better
i operate in an industry where there are
people that think
that think that things will get worse or
people that don't know and are not
interested in investing i accept that
i accept that it will drive prices down
for new investments
and i plan to capitalize upon that
we can um about that as well and let me
tell you one last thing
so so you asked me about
you mentioned that i'm a winner i don't
consider myself a winner i consider
myself somebody who has
winning mentality and he's not willing
to become
a victim of of any circumstances uh and
uh
and and that's that's it he doesn't it
doesn't necessarily
uh uh having that mentality doesn't
necessarily make me a winner i will lose
the times i plan on winning more than i
lose
right and that's that's where i'll be
judged so your next question will you
ask me a question about
the type of investments that we make and
how do we identify
uh how do we identify a
i guess like-minded entrepreneurs and
how do we make that calculation in our
head basically
as investors that this is going to be uh
uh a category defining company right i
mean that was the question
yeah i mean you're looking at a seat
opportunity with minimal data
minimal customers and you have to now
come up with a theory of whether this is
going to be a category king
okay so now so now i'll complicate my
answer a little bit more
um i think it has a lot to do
with at what time you're investing right
and in which categories you're investing
uh and um and how long
and how long have you been investing how
innocent you are and how lucky you are
and who are you investing with so there
are lots of questions that fall into
that
single binary decision of yea or name
right
i tend to invest in companies that are
around seed stage
sometimes i'll venture into investing in
companies that are in their a stage
that means i've joined a little bit
later happens
but it doesn't matter much to me as long
as i believe that the company in which
i've invested can become a category
defining company
and has at least 10x to go right in
terms of in terms of its valuation
so um i i guess that the answer
the short answer is that there isn't
that there isn't a short answer
to how uh to how we make a decision
in the early stages i agree with you
that you have less empirical data so you
have to rely
on the box the sandbox that you kind of
like set
uh uh is kind of like um
as the guiding with the guiding
principles to how you invest
for example in my case if it's not
fintech i don't want to touch it
if it's not business to business okay
i'm not interested in touching it
if it's not a company that is led by
established entrepreneurs
i'm not likely to uh to touch it if we
haven't seen early signs of
growth if we haven't seen contracts that
kind of like give us an indication of
how this company will perform over time
right in touching it if there are
shitload of other competitors in the
marketplace and i don't see how this
company can become a category defining
company
not number three not number four number
one the best
category i'm less interested and lastly
if it's not based in silicon valley with
ties to israel without ties to israel
i'm also less interested
these are the air these are kind of like
the big perimeters right
uh and and uh and then within that
sandbox there are many other
tangible non-tangible things that we
look at including the strength of the
management team
the energy between us and the management
team when we meet in person
and yes i assume i assume that i'll have
to meet people in person when making an
investment decision
uh in the future and and uh and uh
and i guess many other factors and and
also even within fintech there are
certain areas
that i'm excited about there are center
certain areas that i'm not as excited
about so for example
i think neo banks are super cool but for
me to invest in a neobank
because there are 2 000 of them out
there right i need to find i need to
find a very special player that is
playing
that is playing this thing uh in a very
unique way and that's that's by the way
why we invested oh i'm not i'm not
allowed to say we haven't released it
publicly
well this is going to be released only
in about a month so
so that's why i invested in uh in lilly
bank i led
lily bank was formed by um two
co-founders
lilac and liran who started
a pepper bank in israel which is uh oh
okay i love pepper bank
yeah so they started then they left and
they started lily bank which is a
neo bank for freelancers and uh i i led
uh their 10 million dollars seed round
and
i hope it will be public within the next
four months four weeks now
now that they know that this thing is
going to be live only in a month uh uh
i'll uh i'll uh make sure that we're
preparing it in advance
yeah so dobby that's fascinating i have
to draw parallel uh
i found somewhere that you were a
commander
at bad echad or bad one in the army
is that correct okay let's talk about
leadership and i'd love to hear
you know i went through officers academy
in israel i had my share of
frustrations and happy moments within
that
you know very special school of
leadership that's what the army
considers it to be
talk to me a little bit about your
leadership style and i'd love to hear a
little bit about your experience
there as well as now helping
entrepreneurs
lead their companies you know it's been
nobody talked to me about my mother had
experience ever in any interview
there you go you're asking that question
is as
as you said is the israel equivalent to
west point only without getting a degree
at the end of the process right
and uh i i spent almost two years in
barcad
at first first as a uh as a team leader
so
uh uh the one ranked below seventh you
know
uh team leader and and then as uh
which is a company commander in the
direct translation to uh
to uh to english uh and and i've had
literally hundreds hundreds of soldiers
turning uh
turning into officers going uh going
through my pro
my program right uh and uh pretty high
sociometric evaluation this
is that we're competing amongst the
company commanders who's uh
who's better so um
was was great i really some of the best
years of my life i spent at the bad and
um um uh really interesting
really interesting environment as well
right here in the desert
you know the base is just it's like pure
gray dark gray concrete you know
they're like there are four people in
the room you know that
anyway it's spring beds with like so
these tiny mattresses and
anyway it was very unique a very unique
experience um
and i took a lot from it actually that
was the first time in in my adult life
where i felt like uh i can do something
i don't know how to best explain it you
know i was a pretty mediocre
student uh in uh in high school i i left
high school without a diploma
uh because i was i think i was missing
math
missing and i was missing sports and now
you're an investor i'm just
yeah yeah yeah i mean listen don't uh
who knows
but uh you know a and uh
and that was the first time in my life
where i felt like yeah like i ca i can
i can do something and people you know
people can take direction from me and i
can add value to people and so on and so
forth so
that was a that was the first that was a
very very important turning point for me
uh but so i'm happy you asked that
question and then
it relates to managerial style and
leadership style i think that we
bring you know many of us uh immigrants
especially those who left israel came to
the states bring that experience with us
you know i spent four and a half years
in the army
uh and it definitely brings a lot of uh
grit
uh discipline uh uh emo
i guess also emotional intelligence yeah
uh
to to the way i look at uh at managing
my own staff but also to the way i look
at managing my relationships with my
with my founders
and my investors definitely dolby
back to more the investment world i'd
love to hear a little bit a few of your
earned secrets over you know looking at
dozens of companies
that have both failed and succeeded what
are some of the common pitfalls that you
might see
entrepreneurs making and what are some
of the
more unique attributes and this is more
you know
more personal question to me as a young
entrepreneur starting my own path
hopefully one day i'll be sitting next
to you and pitching you my my own
my own venture so what are some of the
things that i should be looking out for
you know in your interview you uh uh
when we prepared for this meeting
uh you sent me uh you sent one of the
questions that you said was
what advice would you give your younger
self yeah
and i thought you know on the way i
drove
i drove to work today yes i am working
from an office
yes uh uh so i i guess i don't really
adhere to the shelter in place thing
although i'm kind of like myself here
but i drove to work today and i was
thinking about this question and the
answer i would have given my young self
is not to listen to me and i'm gonna use
this analogy for a second to answer this
question that you've asked me
not to listen to the adult self i think
coming into something
fob okay fresh off fresh off the boat
inexperience to an extent
and um innocent uh i i think
uh i think uh uh allows you to do things
that you haven't
that you would have never imagined that
you that you'll be able
that you'll be able to do so as i look
at my career backwards and as i'm
thinking about this question that you
just presented me with
uh the answer is that there is no secret
sauce to success
right yes it's easier to build a company
if you have past experience building a
company and that's why i prefer to
invest
in entrepreneurs proven entrepreneurs
because they have that muscle memory
right they've done before they raise
money they saw the company they failed
they succeeded they built a team you
know the whole shebang
um but you're asking me about what
advice i would give entrepreneurs and so
on and so forth just be
be curious be asia be agile you know
find the right partners uh to walk
to walk the long mile with you you know
we are vcs
we are you know when you think about it
in the pyramid about us
where we are in the pyramid we're
somewhere between entrepreneurs
and and uh between uh say people who
have a nine-to-five job right we're
there we're in the middle uh our job is
to enable entrepreneurs
and to enable entrepreneurs doesn't just
mean to look at their financials and say
what's wrong and what's you know
how we can improve but really uh um
to an extent be a mentor as well uh in
in in many cases of young entrepreneurs
and that's
an advice i would give to anybody i
would mentor
just believe in yourself come come in a
sense you know be an outsider to the
problem
because many times where you're an
insider to the problem uh actually i i
stole that one that that that uh phrase
outside of the problem for lauren zev
uh who's my mentor and uh i i liked it a
lot
when you are an outsider to the problem
it's easier to be um
it's either it's easier to be innocent
and it's also easier to revolutionize
or realize in the category right yes and
uh
and and and that's the answer uh uh and
around that
you'll build your team your team and
around that you'll bring your investors
and around that
you'll conquer your first few clients
and around that your story will be built
so that's the long roundabout answer to
your very short and simple question
i love it i love you know and i had
recently a chat for 20 minute leaders
with jill peterson
chairman of the board of jetblue airways
and one of the things that he mentioned
was that along his life
one thing that he thinks is critical for
for entrepreneurs who want to lead
disruption
is to learn how to sell and to learn how
to be sales people and it's not a
and he said it's not the most obvious
answer that you would give to an
entrepreneur because
selling sometimes may seem pushy or may
seem
not the not the sexiest thing to do and
you happen to break a world guinness if
i'm not mistaken
uh at selling and so tell me about this
world
guinness record that you broke yeah i
saw the world's largest life insurance
policy
uh when i was running sg which was a
multi
uh it was a multi-family office
where we managed the wealth of a few
families out of santa barbara and
montecito
i divided the firm to a few divisions
that was before my venture capital
uh career uh uh one was one was
mortgages we did a lot of jumbo
mortgages for wealthy clients
i think almost a billion dollars in java
mortgages a lot was big
volume coming out of that the other part
was uh
alternative uh asset management one
another part was operations where we
helped hinator families manage their
state their yacht their jets etc and the
fourth uh the fourth vertical
was life insurance where through
collaborating with
and a licensed insurance company
we syndicated the term and the whole
life insurance policies
and that's how we sold a 201 million
dollars life insurance policy
unbelievable yeah it was a great it was
a great deal and a very healthy
commission
i got to tell you something you know
that that experience running that firm
through its various divisions helped me
a lot in understanding high net worth
individuals
right and uh and their needs but also
acknowledge
that i'm not that interested in being in
the services in the industry where
you're only as good as your last deal
and that kind of like paved the way for
me to uh to get into venture capital
i was looking for something that has an
upside when you're not you don't just
earn your commission and you move on to
make the next commission i was looking
for something that has longevity
and i was looking for something that has
a positive net impact
uh and uh i i feel very very good about
about where i am today career-wise uh
you have it you have every right to be i
mean it sounds really really fascinating
dobby
before i let you run to doing your
incredible investments i have to ask you
the last and hardest question
i'd like to know three words that best
describe you or that
any of the any of your portfolio
companies would describe adobe francis
as
yeah i don't really care how they
describe me uh uh and that's uh
um i think that's that's because that's
one of the words i think
yeah no i wouldn't say careless i just
don't care how
i i i think i've gotten to a point where
the first word i'll use is complete i
don't really care much about
uh what other people think anymore
because
it's very uh it's very likely whether
they like me or not that they're a
mistake
so uh so i i would like to use the word
complete
uh i would like to use the second word
uh i'll connect them
it's a husband and father uh being a
father is a new muscle
uh for me i you know leo congratulations
by the way
thank you you'll experience it hopefully
soon and uh uh
i took my my sweet time i'm 42. uh
but that defines me today and how i look
at things and
and what drives me you know if back in
the days i was winning i was i was all
about winning for
for the heck of it for sports let's say
or my competition against myself
now i have somebody to win for uh and
somebody will benefit from it
so that makes me very very very happy
that's the second thing and i think the
third thing uh
as i would like to define myself uh
is winner
i love it dolby thank you so so much
this was inspiring
so enjoyable one of the most enjoyable
interviews i've had the pleasure of
doing so far
and then and i really look forward to
sitting in the table together one day
and hopefully forming coming into some
sort of a partnership
i would love it take care all the best